l'humanité franchement c'était quand
même quelque chose enfin pour le temps
que ça a duré
maintenant on peut se le dire on a bien
merdé mais si on fait le bilan on peut
dire aussi qu'on a réussi un sacré truc
non suffit de jeter un oeil à toutes ces
traces de notre passage on en n'était
pas peu fier peut-être trop fier même
tellement qu'on faisait tout pour
immortaliser nos accomplissements
sauf que quand le dernier rome aura mis
la clé sous la porte
il en restera quoi revol
[Musique]
on
dans des attitudes prises sur le vif
comme saisi par un instant l'idée de la
fin du monde avec beaucoup d'optimisme
il paraît qu'il faudra à la terre
quelques millions d'années seulement
pour effacer toute trace de notre séjour
pourtant on n'a pas chômé mais on
pouvait bien bâtir aussi aux qu'on
voulait après nuno flamboyante cité ne
seraient plus que ruines abandonnées
nos positions farouchement conquise les
unes après les autres une fois déserté
serait bien vite reprise par le reste de
la nature en y songeant bien ces
colosses aux artères exsangue qui pourra
encore les différencier de n'importe
quel massif sans petits bonshommes
vaquant à leurs occupations y pensant
même pas une seconde
tout ce qui était là sous nos yeux se
retrouveraient privé de son utilité si
personne n'est plus là pour redonner du
sens c'est juste
bah là
les écrits laissés sur les murs pour la
postérité il pourrait plus être lui même
pas identifié au moins comme de
mystérieux symboles d'une civilisation
disparue si vous voulez la jeunesse en
ce moment depuis on s'est précipité la
consommation reçoit perpignan et elle
éprouve quand même en ses meilleurs
éléments le besoin de s'exprimer et ça
lui est pratiquement impossible
et là tout d'un coup dans le métro sur
des photo efe le détournement c'est
qu'on s'est donné du mal depuis le début
pour laisser des traces
transmettre nos histoires aux autres et
aux générations futures et pour ça
encore faut-il qu'il y en ait des
générations futures
même si une civilisation se casser
complètement la gueule aux suivantes de
trouver tout ça d'essayer de piger ce
que ça pouvait bien vouloir dire et
surtout de conserver à leur tour ce
qu'il en restait et c'est ainsi que nous
avons pu enregistrer les figures qui
sont visibles actuellement en lumière
normale mais également faire des travaux
spéciaux sur les figures qui ont déjà
disparu
bien sûr une bonne partie de ses secrets
seraient perdus à jamais et d'autres
resterait un mystère pourquoi pas on
pouvait au moins se creuser la tête pour
reconstituer une image une histoire de
l'humanité et même d'avant des géants
des temps anciens jusqu'aux débuts de
l'univers lui-même
aujourd'hui nous allons aborder une
question qui est véritablement au coeur
de la science moderne mais qui est aussi
depuis toujours dans la conscience des
hommes
c'est même une des questions
philosophiques les plus anciennes qu'est
ce que la vie à coude science ou de
récits religieux sauf que l'univers lui
eh ben ils s'en tapent
il s'en est toujours taper et il
continuera même sens archéologues du
futur alors que nous mêmes ce qu'ils
auront tout fait pour montrer devant
l'éternité qu'ils étaient les plus
balèze bas n'y aura même plus un pékin
pour capter que depuis là-haut des
siècles le contente
c'était bien la peine de se donner tout
ce mal tient enfin surtout le mal des
autres pour nous mêmes une bâtisse était
pas juste un tas de pierres ça pouvait
aussi servir à raconter une époque une
histoire une vision du monde et surtout
à le transmettre en dur on y tenait
tellement qu'on craignait plus que tout
de les voir disparaître
terrifié par l'oubli on a déployé des
trésors d'ingéniosité pour graver dans
le marbre nos témoignages il faut
admettre qu'on était plutôt doué pour ça
quand le dessin suffisait plus et qu'on
a compris que la paroles s'envolent
on a écrit et comme les écrits c'est pas
grand chose si personne ne les lit on
s'est donné du mal pour les répandre les
conserver et les répandre encore plus
bon les écris ça fait pas tout un
déjà parce que ça peut s'envoler aussi
en fumée notamment et la parole pas
forcément finalement s'étonne et
s'étonne de blabla de mélodies et de
chansons il fallait bien trouver un
moyen de les garder les copier les
écouter il est passé de mains en mains
d'oreilles oreilles
[Musique]
pareil pour les images qui valait à ce
qu'on disait mieux qu'un long discours
on pouvait les figer dans le temps et
même pas forcément figé tient jamais
film de fiction
[Musique]
alors on a enregistré stocker diffusée
sur toujours plus de support ainsi on ne
perdait pas la mémoire et ont peuplé nos
présent des présents de ceux d'avant
à la fin on avait fait pousser des
forêts stocker les mots les sons les
images dans lesquelles on pouvait se
balader depuis n'importe où même depuis
notre poche dans chaque disque dur la
vie de milliers reparti tout devenait
aussi les doubles le plus fou dans tout
ça c'est que ces inventions s'était pas
juste un moyen de copier bêtement un
petit instant tanel d'un fait réel
chaque fois on pouvait pas s'empêcher au
bout d'un moment d'en faire naître un
art une fois qu'on a eus compris qu'on
pouvait leur faire dire quelque chose
d'autre
quelque chose de plus et on rigolait pas
avec ça
un art majeur devant l'initiation wade a
remis york parce que les connards et
caudry qu on nous met des rivets pour
surélever nord une chanson mais si la
journée sinon tu vas y si on sait les
gars qui peut pas oui monsieur
oui c'est parce qu'en réalité ce qu on
transmettait s'était pas juste le monde
qui nous entoure est c'était quelque
part nous le but ça jamais vraiment été
de dire il y avait ça mais plutôt
j'étais là seulement voilà on s'était
dévoué jusqu'au bout pour frôler du
doigt ce moment où toute la mémoire de
l'humanité serait accessible à toute
l'humanité at vitam aeternam
par contre on s'était pas assurée de
conserver l'élément le plus important
pour que tout cela ait le moindre sens
l'humanité elle même
[Musique]
sans elles pour les recevoir leur donner
vie et les transmettre cet océan de
bruit et l'image ne seraient plus que
des fantômes prisonniers dans des boîtes
et parlant dans le vide sans elle les
pages les bangs les pixels les tubes ne
sont eux aussi rien d'autre que des
ruines
c'était à elles d'investir ces trésors
qu'elle avait si précieusement su
conserver sans raconter ses histoires au
coin du feu comme à l'écran faire vivre
ensemble ses souvenirs et ses
millénaires de cultures partager
transmettre transformer et s'inspirer de
ce commun qu'elles avaient su bâtir est
préservé pour apprendre des expériences
et réussite pour faire encore mieux ou
même des erreurs pour parfaire les mêmes
et surtout continuer à maintenir ce lien
avec les autres ceux d'avant ceux de
maintenant et si possible ce d'après
pour la fin du monde france d'avaliser
va là haut sur la montagne on t'attend
mais dans sa valise une simple chemise
pour la fin du monde par de vêtements et
mes photographies des sols est là et ma
boîte à outils les cela aussi mon vieux
tant pis mais pour la fin du monde
devant la valise et voilà
sur la montagne
attends les recettes des bijoux des
machines à sous
on l'a
non pas
genre
ok désolé
makan m
le soleil simon vient tant pis mais pour
la fin du monde quand ta valise et
valence sur la montagne
elle peur de rien et il ira très bien
tout simplement
qui le temps
viendra
l'autre côté
[Musique]
à
marc on va
la drogue
on
[Musique]